welcome to this video playing what PT
nellis meteorite from Brazil but could I
play the trump for change I got this
played against me and I'm not faring
terribly well I think okay yg 6 is the
line that I do like for white i can now
take and set up a very young ammonius
structure wow I play g6 if you go to e7
now that's so interesting ok well my
idea is to go like this see 493 just
very nice bone structure and now here
probably it brings it to g7 okay not not
immediately yeah I'll also play before
just grabbing space and try to try to
make my bishop even stronger okay bishop
is 6 that's interesting should I play d5
immediately or just play more prep moves
c4s hey so I need to react in some way
well if I played d5 what does egg what
exactly is this response yeah if he
takes it yeah it's just just a good
structure right Bishop d7 I take on c6
and I'm just better okay
yeah ok so now this is just a very nice
structure with d5 being really really
weak the question is however how do I
have do I play it I would like to
establish a knight on d5 of course under
95 now I mean just be two hangs so maybe
just hope you keep it simple and maybe
he helps me even and takes on g2 would
be a quite nice no he is not helping me
me okay mmm yeah I can I can't play
before even it's not not bad 94 thoughts
on this all night f4 now everything's
quite nice 95 the move intending reform
not clear
yeah this night efore counterplay it's a
bit it's not so great I mean just just
for a moment protect against this I can
play rook ft one as well after quincy
too ok so maybe preparing it but I can
do night f4 Here I am neither 425
yeah of course my dream scenario okay
this is not going to happen anymore if
my dream scenario would be knight on d5
against the bishop of the dark squared
Bishop on f6 on g7 okay well this is
this Hanks the Queen buddy I'll take it
he wanted to play Queenie five I guess
I'm all slip black resigns I wanted to
play Queen e5 I believe yeah I'll still
upload it because it was interesting
here from the strategical point of view
it's those kind of quick games always
feel a bit unfinished but it was
interesting exactly here it was
interesting because I was thinking that
[ __ ] would be six was really not a good
move because it allows to play d5 and
this should alter the pawn structure
favorably for me I believe that the
catcher would be would be happening and
then I would have taken with the bishop
no maybe that's not even so terrible
from like the point is this is what I
would like to do of course but he can
take me to end I don't want that it's
not clear that this is so terrible for
me but yeah it cannot be ideal getting
the night back end into play so this was
my intention but this is in fact a move
that black can play because I really
don't want to trade on e6 and well
Bishop g2 okay then maybe I'm a bit too
optimistic here and d5 isn't that great
I mean the way it was played it was very
nice and here here there was also before
I considered that but I wasn't sure if I
want to weaken the long diagonal at this
point maybe it's still better simply
because it takes so much space and it
takes c5 away
but ok on its it will be a some sort of
advantage in any case it's just like
that the structures so nice for wider
yeah here as i mentioned i would have
liked to get oops sorry just in 925 and
ok well he took on c3 which i think is
fine and now he needs to play Queen e5
he just disposed a mouse club he needs
to play Queen e5 sorry yeah and this
should be a slightly more comfortable
position for white but not not the end
of the world not quite clear what I
should play actually yeah but it's it's
always a little bit of something because
well the pawn structure there's the
double porn which is not its cell in
itself week but it weakens the overall
structure like the dark squares d6 is
weak and why does not have any
weaknesses so this is is always a bit
yeah but it's not overwhelmingly grade
this is awesome that's interesting
threatening to take on e5 and getting a
bit been winning a pawn not quite sure
like should do really the comp suggests
this one but that looks very comfortable
really it's um already a bit simplified
and looks like i can increase the
pressure like with this this may be
Queen d2 looks quite nice for what yeah
it was it was slightly tricky but ok the
small slip obviously have the lot
alright thanks for watching